es comprensible la preocupación por el
vertido de este líquido que ha estado en
contacto con los reactores O sí que es
seguro realizar el vertido
Bueno en realidad
Qué tal Buenas tardes Perdón primero
saludo te saludo a ti a la audiencia Por
supuesto que es comprensible la
preocupación porque todo digamos toda
manipulación de material radiactivo
entiendo que la población que no tiene
quizás toda la información a la mano se
preocupe pero dicho esto
digamos por un lado habría que poner
esto en dos planos digamos por un lado
es lo que hay que hacer es la forma
segura de hacerlo qué es lo que hay en
en el reactor el reactor acumulado agua
agua que se hay digamos que es
radioactiva porque contiene un
componente que se llama tritio que es un
isótopo un radio isótopo del hidrógeno
es un poquito más pesado que el
hidrógeno sí tiene tiene tres partículas
en su núcleo diferencial hidrógeno que
tiene una y por eso llama tritio Sí el
tritio es radioactivo es Es radioactivo
en un en un nivel bajo Pero quizás la
acumulación de mucho tritio es un
Entonces qué es lo que hay que hacer
Bueno disolver el tritio en grandes
cantidades de agua porque hoy Dónde está
el tritio el Tito está acumulado
digámoslo así en recipientes en el
reactor el agua triada el agua con
tritio como producto del agua utilizada
para evitar digamos para para bajarle la
temperatura y para apagar el reactor y
además el agua que se ha acumulado por
lluvias por fenómenos naturales ese agua
está concentrada alrededor del reactor
tiene muchísimas cantidades de tritio
en el agua porque es un agua con mucha
concentración de tritio porque está
confinada ahí entonces lo que hay que
hacer justamente es reducir la
concentración de Tito en el agua la
mejor manera de hacerlo es irla
disolviendo en el océano de una manera
Por supuesto controlada y de acuerdo a
los estándares que el organismo
internacional de energía atómica plantea
de manera tal que esto no afecte la vida
no solo la vida humana sino la fauna en
el océano es decir la forma en que Japón
anunció que va es una forma correcta y
por otra parte es necesario porque es
mucho más riesgoso seguir concentrando
agua con tanta concentración de tritio
como hay en los recipientes en la
central nuclear eso por un lado por otro
lado no hay otra alternativa es decir lo
ideal sería por supuesto que no hubiera
agua con litio pero hubo un accidente
hace una década eso está ahí y hay que
encarar una solución la mejor solución
es lo que van a hacer por tanto entiendo
por lo que nos está explicando que el
agua directamente iría al océano en
pequeñas cantidades o hay un proceso
intermedio en el que también se intenta
limpiar ese agua no el agua ya ha sido
tratada buena pregunta así digamos
porque no lo había aclarado el agua ya
ha sido tratada se le ha digamos se le
ha
se le han hecho varios tratamientos de
tal manera de quitarle otros elementos
contaminantes es decir el agua está
digámoslo así purificada de otros
elementos pero no manera de sacarle el
tritio en las composiciones que tiene es
decir la única manera de hacerlo es
disolverla en grandes cantidades de agua
el Tito existe en la naturaleza como
otros materiales radioactivos nosotros
estamos expuestos a radiación el sol
digo si uno caminara cuatro días
seguidos por el desierto del Sahara sin
ropa bueno además de morirse ese digamos
pero supongamos que uno tiene agua
estaría expuesto a digamos a radiación
en niveles muy dañinos para la salud
Entonces el problema no es la radiación
sino el nivel de exposición digámoslo
así las cantidades de radiación sí la
cantidad de partículas radiactivas a las
que nos sometemos entonces la mejor
manera de bajar el riesgo es disolver el
agua con litio que ya fue tratada para
liberarla de otros componentes en el
océano hacerlo de manera controlada de
manera digamos pausada de tal manera que
no no cambie las composiciones mínimas
necesarias para que no sea dañino para
la fauna